I am so excited this is perfect like we
used up all the decorations we have we
worked up an appetite and now let's go
get some toujours no pizza cutter ears
and delivery
[Music]
Thank You majora for partnering with us
on this video you let's go eat and our
newly decorated living room
Christmas Pizza don't drop the pizza hey
guys how are you today I'm good
oh you're good thanks for answering so
today is a rare weekend where we
actually have Isaac with us today yeah
yeah I am always so so sad when you go
to your daddy's because I miss you so
much oh my god this house is just so
empty there's no life I mean we do have
these guys oh yeah but they're not the
same they're like moving furniture
though say that about our babies our fur
babies anyway well we have plan for
today is we are going to decorate our
home for the holiday we're gonna get
festive up in her no not really we don't
have a lot of decorations and we
honestly can't even fully decorate this
place like how I wish I could cuz I'll
wear kitty cat they love playing with
our Christmas decorations all the time
when we used to have a Christmas tree it
was like one giant like cat post for
them they just went to town and they
would always pull down our Christmas
tree and it just got to the point where
I got fed up of putting it up every year
and I just donated my Christmas tree to
JK and my care guys use it as a prop
whenever we do Christmas videos and you
see a Christmas tree in the background
that was my tree instead now I ended up
buying a mini tree that I've been
putting it for the last two years it's
so cute it's so small I'll show you guys
in a minute but nothing looks so fat
look at that belly I serve everything -
do you motorboat of those like just
bother daddy or see the Hat actually no
keep going that feels good but anyway
yes so that's the plan we're gonna try
to put up the Christmas decorations that
I have but again it's not like a whole
big old thing even the amount of
decorations that I do already put up
they the cats will still mess with it
I'm like trying
- squeeze him a little bit of that
holiday spirit in this home where you
going again I forgot or supplies you
wants great smell flourish juice things
like that I'll be back Hey all right
baby the garage door open by the way oh
yeah I leave it open for light all right
baby
it's me and you you ready to decorate
yeah maybe you should learn some
Christmas songs so then next time we go
to buy my ideas house complained
Christmas yeah how did you believe and
play your piano you still be but oh it's
the God oh look at you
musical genius I don't know what that
means means you 10min relief s oh all
right let's go to the garage and get
some Christmas stuff oh no daddy forgot
to leave the garage open no stop closing
it
what happened by
so here we have X myth all right let's
see what we have in these boxes oh look
yeah you know my aunt made this I think
I mentioned this in a previous vlog but
she actually handmade this she made this
one too she put my name on it
I've had this since I was like seven
years old or eight years old and then we
have this sled not this again what
happened whoa what about this you're
scared of this snowman still dude you're
almost 11 come on I know I saw you know
my dad still has a fear of dolls thing
so I bought this for nothing
okay I could I could man up yay good job
baby I'm proud of you yeah and then I
have this tis the season Merry Christmas
are you scared of that the only snowman
you're scared of them
[Music]
you're scared of this guy huh what's in
here I feel like we're opening presents
I know it's an early Christmas take out
the bag candles yeah Mele smells good
you know what it smells like to me like
the most wonderful time of the year and
now Joe it's an appropriate time to sing
that song it's Joe sing it what we got
engaged no this is creepy new yeah it
has like actual hair are you scared of
this doll no no no this one yes so it
has to have some sort of hair yeah
and real life thing tiny little
ornaments but a tiny little tree this is
the only Christmas tree we can have and
the cats still attack it master
[Music]
tada
high five baby whoa look at our finished
tree it's not the greatest but it's okay
it'll do it's giving us the Christmas
spirit oh my gosh I totally feel like
Christmas now last year I didn't put up
any decorations and it did feel kind of
like missing you know what's funny - I
didn't realize this and I didn't do this
on purpose but our entire living room
decor it's kind of Christmasy there's
like red and blue and white and green
with the greenery all right so we're
done with the tree so no where's that
little kitty or there's Maya
Maya's hiding over there she's just
waiting for us to finish decorating so
she could attack it aren't you Maya
aren't you why are you so cute Maya
[Music]
we did it baby whoa how do you like it I
like it I know I was haha thank you I'm
so proud - I'm proud of us whoo-hoo
so the last time I did this decoration
we were filming here and so when I did
that Garland really high up you couldn't
see it so I ended up putting down here
by the floor but then the cats just
loved it like they went so crazy and
then for these hanging things I had it
up here where they were dingaling and
then even as I was trying to put this up
the cats are trying to play with it
already so I'm like okay how can I put
this in a way where it's the least
likely that they will play with it and I
feel like I came up with a pretty good
solution hopefully this works I like it
I like it a lot
starting to look really festive in here
baby oh we should turn on these lights -
we have these year-round but it kind of
looks like Christmas no turn it on yeah
you know what what was I saying before
I'm trippin this living room is
Christmas all year round I should have
that holiday spirit in me all year round
now we actually have our Christmas tree
for today or for this year
oh this thing was really zoomed in yeah
hopefully when you guys were looking at
me just now it wasn't like crazy so she
it's pretty funny so daddy just got home
ha I'm excited to see his face yeah he's
about to walk in through that door well
it's gonna take some time cuz he just
parked looks those ready for him to
that's so cute
Merry Christmas
like you're so funny there's just only
that wall right it looks pretty good so
the Christmas tree and then the garland
and then that garland which I think
they're called Garland's I don't know I
keep forgetting that's a garland right
like GA RL a and B the first 10 years of
my life I lived in town called Garland
yeah now you know what I mean
darlin when I was in third grade it was
this kid that lived in my apartment
building and his name was Garland and I
had the biggest crush on him so for the
longest time that's what I would
associate the word
garland with hey I like how garland has
like we're childhoods are linked to
garland yeah that funny
yeah but then also like who names their
kid Garland anyway look we saw this box
sit open
oh there's a whole Santa Claus in here
you want to get out all night you put it
up baby you're scared of this one too
Gary I'm just kidding no he's Santa
he brings you presents come on Bert like
a few years ago I've been it over here I
know and you faced it like make me
facing the wall I'll actually leave it
there like how it looks like you don't
like it
[Music]
look as though he's already going at it
I already called it look at this I
caught you fool
I caught you red-handed
right in front of me you don't even care
you don't even care that I caught you
[Music]
we can take this out with this stocking
all I see what you mean Mike put it
through here
[Music]
hey hey good job good idea yeah what
should we name future children to make
that an even better word okay
tick oh yeah with the Ben H magic we
actually name our kids solely based off
of sake tick like it can be quick yes so
the the girl could be Karen Oh Karen and
then the last thing it could be
Sebastian well the other one the brother
the brother Sebastian okay well I guess
our future kids names are picked out
Karen is Sebastian there we go no I
thought I am getting hungry baby do you
want to eat I like the way you think my
boy Cheers
all right what is that on your head
a flashlight we're gonna play
hide-and-go-seek in the dark
last time we did this it was in our old
house and I was really little that me I
was brave apparently you're a brave how
come cuz right now I'm screwed scared
what are you scared of the Santa I
thought you said you weren't afraid of
Senator Morra play hard you'll be okay
alright so it's been a few hours since
we had the pizza
we've been chilling today now how to
boredom we've decided to do a little bit
of hide-and-go-seek
in the dark yeah we've actually been
wanting or at least I've been wanting to
do this for a few years but either
Isaac's not here or he's too scared
because I actually suggested it a few
times over the years he's like no I'm
scared
but now thinks I'm gonna need to do it
so we all got our headlamps now I have
an extra flashlight nice get X
protection yeah do it so now I'm gonna
read the one that's thinking seeking
first all right so I'm gonna go outside
through the balcony and I'm gonna let
these guys hide I'm gonna count to how
long how long do you want 36 30 seconds
that's a really short time oh time it
for like oh sorry two minutes I'll give
you two a minute all right so once I
open up the balcony I'm gonna be like
ready or not here I come so think about
your hiding spot already got it
wait where you going you're giving me a
clue let your up here already there you
are or maybe you can just let me go to
the bathroom first
your must be down here see down here
okay turn up all the light separately
though all right
I'm here in the balcony area so the last
time we played hide-and-seek in the dark
Isaac was like six years old I think he
was so brave because in that old house
that we lived in it was so creepy like I
was even scared um and we played a few
times too it wasn't just like a one-time
thing
oh and we also played hide and seek I
didn't seek in the dark in our first
apartment with Casey - so we've been
like a continuous thing that we've done
over the years but yeah it's been a
really long time since we've done it the
last time I get sick actually suggested
it which I was really shocked because
he's been really scared of playing this
but yeah really looking forward to
seeing where they hide because I usually
like hiding I try to get as creative as
possible like I hid in the hamper once
and they couldn't find me all right it's
go time
[Applause]
ready or not here I come captain where
are you guys so tell me where they are
oh you're gonna give me some clues oh
this is light too bright
give me pie Maya are you giving me a
clue someone over here nope she ran away
oh I saw some slippers and I thought I'd
caught someone oh they left it they left
the closet open to throw me off huh
there's no one in here how about under
here nope right office is clear
the Isaacs bedroom
hmm the cow just pushed out that's
pretty pushed out pretty obvious let's
let me see where is Isaac this closets a
disaster I don't think you could fit in
here he's not in here
see in the bathroom are you in here no
there's no one in there let me check my
room actually and I really checked my
room you and my closet nope I am I
thought it'd be in the bathroom
nope okay he must be downstairs then
we actually have the kitchen and the
living room still Isaac are you this is
scary this is really creepy let me see
it's a vantage point hmm I don't see
anyone hiding down here you see where
could he be
yeah that kind of ramp this is actually
really creepy so the cats keep following
me everywhere and they keep making
noises dang where's Isaac oh I didn't
check in here are you in here boy no
not in here oh man I can't find Isaac
and I'm kind of out of breath oh is he
in a hamper you know I actually thought
about that too I was like man you not in
there because I saw the sweater covering
it good job baby gets dumped oh man was
it hot in there
oh man I can actually see light in yes
it was and help fighting I should have
known you guys were in the same room
together you told me that you didn't
want to hide in different rooms all
right well you know I should have taken
that as a clue too because right before
we started doing this I feel like what
if we have partners when we hide because
just so that it's less scary we could be
like together when we're hiding I should
have known he was in this room do you
want to film this or we should just put
the camera away they got one game
it's okay okay guys next time we're
gonna keep playing
[Music]